jamais les visionneurs aimant la crise
interne assez l'homme s'était fait à 64
ans à los angeles qu'il était atteint
d'un cancer de la gorge
vive émotion à l'assemblée nationale
après l'agression à royan la professeure
d'histoire ou et de plus par deux
inconnus masqués parce qu'elle avait
condamné la profanation de carpentras en
côte d'ivoire les militaires mécontents
haute occupé une partie de la journée la
télévision est l'aéroport le président
houphouët boigny leur a demandé de
déposer les armes
enfin françois mitterrand en polynésie
pour une visite officielle de trois
jours le chef de l'état a appelé les
élus à l'ucly contre les inégalités
bonsoir le petit homme était très grand
le destin ne l'avait pourtant pas aidé
il avait grandi dans un ghetto de harlem
pauvres noirs et borgne mais il était
sorti très vite du gâteau pour conquérir
le monde
sammy davis junior nous quitte
aujourd'hui il est mort d'un cancer de
la gorge et on le regrettera morad aït
habbouche peu de temps après le verso
déjà sur une scène à tout petits pas de
danse c'est médavy junior conjuguait
tous les talents chanteurs acteurs
danseurs imitateur et musicien il savait
faire rire aussi frères d'armes des plus
grands sinatra bop et dean martin jerry
lewis qui claquent et sur tous les
rythmes toutes les musiques
brunner quelquefois ce petit homme et
c'est le plus grand des perfectionnistes
5000 vient de disparaître
hommage d'un ami m
tu sais je t'aime je ne peux rien dire
de plus tu es mon frère frise une
catholique et d'un bâtisse émis d'avis
étaient juifs noirs et borgne son plus
grand mérite avoir réconcilié tout le
monde grâce à sa musique universelle
réaction d'un homme qui connaissait bien
mister wonderful charles aznavour salut
l'artiste est l'ami témoignages
recueillis à l'instant à cannes par jean
françois grégoire
je veux dire que la france perd un ami
en plus du grand artiste qu'il était il
adorait la france
et c'est un homme qui a une dimension
assez fantastique parce qu'il a assumé
toutes ces croyances d'une part il a
fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour que son
peuple puisse vivre normalement aux
états unis ensuite à une époque où on
parle de racisme et d'antisémitisme et
il a suivi ses croyances et l heure qui
s'est converti au judaïsme et c'est une
énorme perte c'est une bande tristesse
pour moi en tant que spectateur une
barre est encore plus grande en tant
qu'ami ce ne sont sans doute pas les
mêmes jambes mais ils le font pour les
mêmes raisons après avoir profané des
cimetières il s'attaque maintenant aux
individus une enseignante a été agressé
par deux hommes masqués à royan cette
femme professeur d'histoire a été
littéralement roué de coups par deux
inconnus masqués qui l'ont frappé à
l'intérieur même de son domicile motif
elle avait condamné samedi la
profanation de carpentras lors d'un
cours d'instruction civique donner à ses
élèves
après avoir perdu connaissance elle a
été transportée à l'hôpital où elle est
toujours sous surveillance
reportage fr3 poitiers je pense que
c'est lié ou cours d'éducation civique
que j'ai fait aux enfants samedi matin
qui porte qui est parti d'un fait très
grave celui de carpentras et que j'ai
donc liés aux cours d'instruction
civique qu'en développant la déclaration
des droits de l'homme de 48 et la loi
contre le racisme de 72 pendant le
week-end christian guillard reçu chez
elle plusieurs appels anonymes des
inconnus l'ont menacé de mort et lundi
matin deux hommes l'ont agressé à son
domicile ou du couloir j'ai je fus deux
hommes qui étaient près la salle à
manger avis il empêche l'autre vian
bleus et il portait un mba sur la figure
et a fendu d'une rude coup y traiter de
sale gîte du sel à rome ils ont dit que
ce qui était prévu
nous allons retrouver en direct de
poitiers monsieur henri legault url
recteur de l'académie de poitiers
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous avez vu j'imagine aujourd'hui
madame christine gaillard comment se
porte-t-elle ce soir monsieur marc je
rentre à l'instant de royan où j'ai été
porté à madame guillard tout
l'expression de la solidarité de la
sympathie de toute la communauté
éducative
toutes catégories confondues élèves
enseignants parents d'élèves
j'ai vu madame diyar elles se portent
physiquement aussi bien que possible
elle est très marqué moralement et c'est
sur ce plan là qu'il faudra que nous
fassions tout pour l'aider bien je vous
propose monsieur orel d'écouter le
ministre de l'éducation monsieur jospin
qui a tenu à parler de cette agression
cet après midi à l'assemblée nationale
que j'ai cette agression j'ai fait
connaître directement à madame dia par
un message personnel ma sympathie et ma
solidarité
l'inspecteur d'académie lui a
immédiatement rendu visite
je précise d'ailleurs que le recteur de
l'académie
keira endredi dans la classe de madame
billard pour symboliquement la remplacer
et parler à ses élèves des valeurs de la
république et de la démocratie que notre
école admission de diffuser
mais chez nos graines qu'allez vous dire
aux élèves
je leur dirai d'abord une chose
importante je dors direct comment la
communauté israélite est entré voici
deux siècles dans la communauté
française
je crois qu'il est très important qu'il
sache que au delà du bicentenaire nous
avons célébré se situe toute la
formation de la nation française qui est
complexe dans sa diversité dans ses
origines
et c'est précisément pour ça qu'il faut
que nos jeunes sachent comment apprécier
l'autre leur garder l'estimé et puis les
mais il ya quelque chose qui nous qui
nous intrigue royan et comme carpentras
une ville tranquille où il n'y a pas de
problème raciste comment cette agression
at elle pu se produire
vous me posez une question monsieur marc
à laquelle je n'ai pas de réponse c'est
vrai que royan est une ville tranquille
l'académie de poitiers est une académie
de france où nous avons le moins de
population immigrée de quelle que soit
la génération d'immigration et je n'ai
pas de réponse si ce n'est qu'il y a je
pense à royan comme partout certains
extrémistes est ce qu'il pourrait s'agir
de parents d'élèves ecoutez-la relents
kate est en cours là je ne peux pas vous
donner d'éléments aucun élément non et
vous avez semble-t-il des informations
je crois qu'il faut laisser aux
autorités de police et de justice soin
de mener enquête une plainte a été
déposée et j'ai ce que je sois de ses
cales aboutisse rapidement car moi je
n'ai pas de mots assez forts pour
condamner un acte aussi odieux
la violence n'est jamais admissible pour
faire triompher une idée mais quand des
enseignants pour qui la liberté de
parole dans l'exercice de leur mission
éducative est quelque chose d'essentiel
corps des enseignants sont attaqués
comme cela a été le cas pour madame
diyar jeudi où va-t-on et vous risquez
vous chassiez d'être menacé la cour vous
savez la mission de recteur est une
mission difficile je le sais et je n'ai
pas peur merci monsieur le recteur ellis
un carpentras près d'une semaine après
la profanation du cimetière juif
l'enquète se resserre sur la ville même
michel rocard a annoncé cet après midi
l'envoi de 60 enquêteurs supplémentaires
sur place tout de suite le point sur les
enquêtes marié dîne pas nièce
et si les profanateurs venait tout de
même de carpentras après avoir enquêté
son succès à marseille aix et salon de
provence
les policiers reprennent leurs
recherches à carpentras et plusieurs
habitants de la ville aurait été entendu
aujourd'hui selon les mots du procureur
chapon pourquoi aller chercher si loin
ce que l'on peut trouver devant sa porte
d'autant que l'interprétation de
certains faits pourraient étayer cette
thèse
ainsi une plaque funéraire portant
l'inscription souvenir des voisins
auraient été placées près du corps de
philippe germond lors de la profanation
dans le cimetière
difficile de trouver de nouveaux indices
dans le sol a été piétinée et certains
policiers n'hésitent pas à faire état de
négligence au départ de l'enquète
c'était michel rocard annoncé l'envoi à
carpentras de 60 enquêteurs spécialisés
supplémentaires
une manifestation ait lieu cet après
midi à clermont ferrand 4000 personnes
ont protesté contre cette profanation
parmi ces personnes valéry giscard
d'estaing mais il n'ya pas que les
cimetières
une église a été profanée dans le var à
draguignan
la statue du christ a été lapidée et un
bénitier a été endommagée la police elle
aussi doit parfois faire face à des
débordements c'est le cas dans le sud
est de la france où l'inspecteur lecanu
connu pour ses opinions d'extrême droite
a été inculpé dans le cadre des
attentats contre les foyers sonacotra
aujourd'hui le conseil de discipline de
la police a proposé sa révocation
l'inspecteur lecanu et pourtant libre
depuis plusieurs semaines béatrice
nivois relâche il ya un mois et demi par
la cour d'aix-en-provence serge le cas
nous n'en n'a pas fini de ses démêlés
avec la police
inculpé dans le cadre des attentats
contre les foyers sonacotra de la côte
d'azur
le conseil de discipline de la police
propose aujourd'hui sa révocation
une proposition qui intervient quelques
jours après la révocation par pierre
joxe de quatre policiers d'extrême
droite impliqué dans les mêmes attentes
à une proposition qui intervient
quelques heures après la fin du congrès
de la fédération autonome des syndicats
de police la phase qui s'est inscrit
sous le signe de la lutte contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme
y compris dans la police l'inspecteur
serge lecanu était membre actif du parti
nationaliste français européen et de la
peep fédération professionnelle et
indépendante de la police
un syndicat d'extrême droite un syndicat
qui a recueilli presque 7% des voix lors
des dernières élections dans la police
les plaintes contre maurice papon on
était déposée par les familles des
victimes de la déportation maurice papon
et et je vous le rappelle le secrétaire
général de la préfecture de gironde
pendant la guerre albert ripamonti après
carpentras la motivation des parties
civiles est encore plus grande pour elle
il faut que le dossier papon soit
définitivement clos avant la fin de
l'année preuve de leur détermination en
début d'après midi leurs avocats se
rendent chez le juge munis de 23
nouvelles plaintes en crimes contre
l'humanité fait nouveau
elle concerne cette fois des
déportations survenu en 1943-44 deux
années durant lesquelles maurice papon
affirme avoir joué double jeu
un pied dans l'administration de vichy
l'autre dans la résistance
un numéro d'équilibriste auquel ne croit
guère les familles des victimes qu'il
accuse d'avoir fait déporter 17 demain
samedi 17 membres de ma famille d'avoir
signé des papiers de ne pas essayé
d'avertir les gens la position qu'ils
avaient ils pouvaient très bien le faire
durant la guerre 1690 personnes ont été
raflés dans la région bordelaise et
diriger ensuite vers les camps de la
mort
parmi elles 2 123 enfants le plus jeune
âgé seulement de trois mois peut-on
supprimer les juges d'instruction la
question est brutale mais la rumeur
court sur une réforme radicale de leur
statut et juge son papier on ça n'est
pour le moment qu'une rumeur une réunion
plutôt les éléments d'un rapport qui
pourrait être la base d'une réforme du
code de procédure pénale les
indiscrétions qui provoque une véritable
tempête au sein de la magistrature
explications jean marc pitte en outre 88
le ministre la justice pierre
arpaillange constituer une commission
chargée de réfléchir à une réforme du
code de procédure pénale cette
commission des lois marty n'a pas encore
publié son rapport
mais déjà des informations filtrent
parmi ces propositions on trouverait la
possibilité pour les avocats de la
défense d'assister aux gardes à vue
celle pour le garde des sceaux de
classer une affaire
enfin la suppression des juges
d'instruction qui suscite l'indignation
de certains syndicats de magistrats on
veut la peau du juge d'instruction est
depuis longtemps parce que précisément
il est efficace pour les raisons qui
nous font nous souhaiter le maintien du
juge d'instruction
il y a des gens qui ne supportent pas
cette espèce de
honneur que peut représenter le juge
d'instruction gêneurs bien entendu dans
les affaires sensibles pour les
responsables politiques et dieu sait qu
aujourd'hui la classe politique peut
avoir des raisons de craindre certaines
investigations de ce petit juge trop
curieux génère aussi pour certains
grands avocats richissime influente
issime illustrissime qui ne supporte pas
de queue devant ce qu'ils appellent le
même des petits juges
il ne pèse pas plus lourd que la valeur
des causes qu'ils défendent
on passerait ainsi de notre procédure
inquisitoire à la procédure accusatoire
anglo saxon l'avocat de la défense et la
police ils sont conjointement
responsables de l'instruction elle est
plus rapide
reste à savoir si elle offre les mêmes
garanties le rapport de la commission ne
sera officiellement rendue qu'à la mi
juin
en attendant sa présidente mireille
delmas-marty se refuse à expliquer des
éléments qu'elle juge disparates
inexacte et incomplète des peines de
prison dans la plupart avec sursis c'est
ce qu'a requis est aujourd'hui le
procureur général à l'encontre de sept
des prévenus dans la sphère des caisses
noires de l'as saint-etienne
inquisitoire long très long
les joueurs s'en tire à bon compte les
dirigeants en revanche sont très
nettement vie des comptes rendus
d'audience de nos envoyés spéciaux à
lyon caroline since et philippe pensait
seuls les fans des verts faisaient
aujourd'hui le pied de grue sur les
marchés du palais toujours fidèle au
rendez-vous les six dirigeants de la fse
alors que les joueurs l'été venu cassis
le procureur a bat elle commence son
réquisitoire en comparant cette affaire
à un drame lyrique de wagner et dans ce
drame les acteurs principaux sont bien
les ex-dirigeants de la fse roger rocher
en tête crochet a menti répète plusieurs
fois le procureur crochet et le chef
d'orchestre de la caisse noire ajoute
t-il malgré les circonstances
atténuantes qu'il lui accorde la peine
qu'ils recueillaient et la plus lourde 3
ans de prison dont un an ferme et 100
mille francs d'amendé
louis arnaud vice-président de la fse
est décrit comme le premier violon de ce
drame
deux à trois ans de prison avec sursis
et 200 mille francs d'amendé
à l'issue de cette longue audience roger
rocher est donc celui qui a été retenu
comme coupables numéro un dans la sphère
de la caisse noire
quant aux joueurs et à l'entraîneur le
procureur laisse le soin au tribunal de
trancher
tahiti a beau être un paradis mais
apparemment pas pour tout le monde et
françois mitterrand a tenu à le
souligner dès son arrivée en polynésie
française
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
françoise roy et georges milan voix et
son arrivée à papeete françois
mitterrand a reçu un accueil
traditionnel à la tahitienne vahiné
chant et colliers de fleurs accueil
mitigé cependant puisque à l'extérieur
de l'aéroport une centaine de militants
du front de libération de la polynésie
conduit par le maire de la commune de
faa'a oscar temaru qui se trouve situé
l'aéroport sont venus manifester leur
hostilité au chef de l'état
ils souhaitent l'indépendance de la
polynésie et l'arrêt des essais
nucléaires à mururoa procès à sa sortie
de l'aéroport le président de la
république s'est rendu au monument aux
morts puis à l'assemblée territoriale ou
consciente des difficultés économiques
et sociales de la polynésie
le président de la république a promis
d'aider le territoire sous certaines
conditions
l'état et je vous le dit disposé à
secondes et vos efforts à une triple
condition la mobilisation des capitaux
la formation de la main d'oeuvre
l'amélioration de la desserte aérienne
il faudrait bien introduire une
fiscalité sur les revenus
votre territoire ne pourra continuer de
faire exception au sein de la république
de même égalité des chances exige celle
des conditions de vie au cours de son
voyage de trois jours en pacifique sud
françois mitterrand devrait inaugurer
les cérémonies
marquant le centenaire de la création de
la commune de papeete avant de présider
jeudi la réunion du conseil supérieur du
pacifique sud qui coordonne la politique
de la france en polynésie en côte
d'ivoire nervosité au sein de l'armée
cet après midi depuis plusieurs jours
déjà les militaires mécontents de leurs
soldes avaient manifesté abidjan mais
aujourd'hui la poule la colère est
montée d'un cran ils ont occupé pendant
une partie de la journée la télévision
est l'aéroport le président houphouët
boigny les a sommés de regagner leurs
casernes correspondance de la sp à
abidjian bernard nicolas ce matin les
rues d'abidjan
mais ce n'était pas un coup d'état
simplement une sorte de grève des
appelés du contingent ceux qui sont
libérables prochainement ils ont des
revendications de salariés il exige
d'être maintenue sur les drapeaux
jusqu'à l'âge de 55 ans on va vers
l'armé des papilles ils veulent possible
une solde mensuel d'au moins mille six
cent trente sept pour les premières
places
et enfin un corner carrière débuta envie
de prix la télévision est aussi
l'aéroport à la barbe des paras français
ans et garder cette idylle en belgique
les gendarmes ont pris deux blindés et
ont repris la télévision à temps pour
les journal télévisé de la mi-journée
le gouvernement a donc appelé les butins
à déposer les armes et regagner les
casernes et les ne dit rien de leurs
revendications
reste à savoir si insurgés ont conservé
le potentiel de sympathie dont il
dispose et ça mettra dans la population
depuis ils ont multiplié les
réquisitions de taxi pour se déplacer
fait le plein sans piller et surtout ils
vont piller des marchés populaires
un télégramme à l'instant un attentat
s'est produit à l'ombre une explosion
s'est produite à wembley dans le
nord-ouest de la capitale anglaise
elle a fait un mort et un blessé grave
elle a été provoquée par une bombe
placée dans un véhicule militaire
en france ce nouveau record mondial de
vitesse pour le tgv 510,8 km/heure et
les premières images de ce splendide
record si tout de suite les autres faits
marquants de l'actualité
éric thibault
ça va très très vite ces images ont été
filmées le 9 mai dernier la rames du tgv
atlantique a atteint ce jour-là 500 10,6
km heure entre courtalain et tours
mais la sncf vient encore de faire mieux
cet après midi cinq cent dix huit
kilomètres heure mais jusqu'où iront les
cheminots c'est pour s'être intéressée
de trop près à la fatigue de ses élèves
qu'un enseignant danger vient d'être
licencié bernard carré en menant
l'enquêté a constaté que la moitié des
apprentis travaillait plus de quarante
six heures par semaine et six jours sur
sept pour 37% d'entre eux bref la
chambre des métiers du maine et loire
qui dirige le centre d'apprentissage n'a
pas du tout apprécié mais c'est avec le
soutien de ses élèves que bernard gare
et demande aujourd'hui sa réintégration
59 salariés de la dernière manufacture
horlogère française vont être licenciés
la société cattin fondé en 1929 a déposé
son bilan le 8 mai dernier
les juges lui ont donné six mois pour
trouver une solution la municipalité de
morteau a décidé d'organiser demain une
opération ville morte
c'est à l'unanimité que les marins de la
société nationale corse méditerranée ont
voté aujourd'hui la reprise du travail
le danielle casanova reprendra la mer
dès ce soir entre ajaccio et marseille
ce bébé à tout juste quelques heures il
baisse 2 kg 270 ce sont des enfants qui
l'ont trouvée à 15 heures dans un bois
près d'amiens ce petit garçon a dû
l'être dans la matinée selon les
médecins il est en bonne santé
van gogh reconnu cent ans plus tard mais
bien reconnu 450 millions 457 millions
c'est le prix de l'un de ses tableaux
vendus hier à new york le portrait du
docteur gachet très acide à toi la plus
chère du monde
claude heymann vincent van gogh a peint
le docteur gachet il y a un siècle
quasiment jour pour jour c'était à
auvers sur oise dans les derniers mois
de sa courte vie gâchée lui même peintre
à ses heures était médecin homéopathe et
s'entendait très bien avec van gogh
vincent en a tiré deux toiles dont l'une
est au musée d'orsay avec de faibles
différences par rapport à celle que
vient de négocier la galerie japonaise à
l'époque van gogh espérer gagner de
l'argent avec ces deux toiles auprès
précisément de la clientèle du docteur
il lui aura fallu attendre un siècle
pour devenir le peintre le plus côté de
la planète celui que antonin artaud
appelé le suicidé de la société serait
aujourd'hui l'un de ses hommes les plus
riches
et pour conclure ce 19 ans nous allons
nous rendre à cannes avec la
présentation d'un film coproduit par fr3
la plus un bureau avec celle corti un
film en compétition avec deux acteurs
phares l'américain timothy dalton et la
belle italienne valeria golino que
dominique poncet christophe airaud ont
rencontré la [ __ ] du roi la voici
elle s'appelle valeria golino et au box
office
elle monte elle monte cette jeune
napolitaine on commence à s'arracher en
italie et qu'hollywood réclament malgré
son jeune âge c'est déjà son troisième
festival de cannes
mais pour elle ce n'est pas une sinécure
c'est un beau film
mais là deux autres beaux films aussi il
faut pourquoi vous dites ça pour moi je
pense pas parce que c'est un beau rôle
que vous avez latin rôle fort violent
oui c'est je suis sûr qu'il a des autres
femmes d'actrice qui sont mieux que moi
dans ces festivals alors pas de budaj
pas de déjeuner en ville pas deviner pas
de soirées folles par des croisés que je
suis même pas qu'est ce que ça veut dire
trois aides caf et la mère une vie
d'ascète fait que ça c'est pas le fait
qu'on prend non mais ça va merci fabrice
nous fera rire à 20h et chico buarque
vous fera danser à 20h35 marque
hautement vous informera à 22h15 et tout
de suite florence klein va vous donner
la météo complète de la soirée bonsoir à
demain 19h à demain soir